please wear this ring that is your first
look right there at Jade and Tanner
tying the knots after falling in love on
bachelor in paradise
the ceremony has been turned into a TV
special surprise that looks back at
bachelor history but it could also be a
look ahead at what is in store for Ben
if he finds his soulmate you want more
special to me today than yesterday you
will be more cherished tomorrow
we're on our wedding there's a lot of
love here let's celebrate how are you
feeling on a day like today does it make
you think about what your own friends
and family celebrating that's what I
want that's the only thing I ask it away
for good food good drink
music Ben's getting down on the dance
floor and Sharons and bachelor in life
lessons be open to anything but also
just the fact that you can date multiple
people one time it's a possibility
it worked for these couples Trista and
Ryan were the first ones to say I do
you guys are so the success story of the
the bar that is set for everyone else I
feel very maternal towards everyone
because I I was kind of fair from the
beginning Kaitlyn and Shawn are engaged
what are the wedding plans at this point
what's the update I feel like the
pressure is gonna be on big time after
today I remember when bachelor Jason had
a shocking change of heart and left
Melissa for Molly
I'm solo my wife's at home with the baby
so it's totally different showing up
like I'm like a single guy here there
will be a better wedding you see you can
make out have sex on TV and still find
true love sometimes though just ask it
last year's bachelor partner crystals
are you dating what's your relationship
status currently sir I am single and you
know enjoying just sort of being normal
if you can with their shaky hands please
place the ring on Tanner's finger and
repeat after me
Jade and Tanner's wedding is just in
time for Valentine's Day it's part of
the bachelor 20 a celebration of love
airing Sunday on ABC it's my third
bachelor bachelorette wedding to
officiate we're just kind of near and
dear and special to me this is a big
a televised wedding what are some of the
perks are we getting some free deals
today yeah suits are free the you know
the dinner is free everything I
recommend it to everyone at home you
know get married on TV it's a breeze at
the end of the day it's this guy and
this girl looking at each other having a
moment and just hoping praying in you
know hopefully falling in love and
that's it there's that innocent awkward
crazy moment and that will never change
you